welcome to nostalgia trip the show where
we stroll down memory lane to see how
our favorite games from the past hold up
today Michael I'm joined by jean-luc and
we have a treat for all of you out there
because we're going back to Black Mesa
to see how half-life holds up today
[Music]
before steam became an absolute giant
for PC game distribution developer valve
debuted in 1998 with the first-person
shooter
half-life on PC and it was nothing short
of revolutionary at the time half-life
served as the foundation for nearly
every FPS that soon followed breaking
new ground for what shooters could be
with its cleverly scripted combat
sequences and narrative entirely told
through the eyes of Gordon Freeman
half-life also spawned numerous mods
that became great games in their own
right and one that revolutionised
multiplayer shooters as well
counter-strike it would take a whole
history lesson to analyze half life's to
influence through the years but we're
here specifically to discuss why it's
remembered as one of the greatest games
and whether or not you should play it
today so we understand that half-life is
one of the most influential games of all
time but we really want to break down
how the gameplay elements and how the
narrative style holds up today gentlemen
gonna throw it to you to talk about I
want to talk about the combat a little
bit ok what do you like after playing it
now what are some of the things that you
notice in playing half-life
well the combat is a mixed bag today ok
so how I would describe it the weapon to
feel is is a bit like stiff is the word
for it ok I think some weapons feel
really good but there's a lack of
response from some of the enemies I want
to say and when you're shooting them and
for yourself when you're like you're
taking damage yeah so it's really easy
to just like get into a firefight and
feel like oh I'm suddenly have no health
or you know in the case of I noticed
this with the Marines wouldn't get to
the marine section and you get the
assault rifle which i think is a
terrible assault rifle absolutely awful
and you're just sitting there you just
shooting them and they're just soaking
up bullets and you're like eventually
they'll fall down yeah
yeah I feel that the same way when it
comes to feedback and response with the
weapons exactly there are some good
weapons of the shotgun really feels like
a cat's a punch yeah and the revolver is
real dope for long-range situations
especially but what I notice is that in
half life when they give you all these
weapons you're constantly shuffling
between the weapons to deal with
different types of enemies so when I
look back at how these scripted
sequences are set up it's more of like I
am I'm constantly responding to the
different types of enemies so in that
and I'm mentally juggling what I have to
do I mean whether or not these weapons
feel great is a kind of separate from
that but the fact that I have all of
these different types of weapons to use
I think that it makes these these combat
arenas a lot more interesting yeah and
you know it's when you look at
first-person shooters like soon after
half-life they all took a note of that
and in some games like Medal of Honor
and Call of Duty
went from scale on they went for more
realistic type of types of combat
situations and firefights but something
about half-life and where they asked you
to juggle all these things I think it's
something special that you know we might
not see in many games today yeah no I
think the combat encounters like the way
they're designed is actually so pretty
good there's something about the way
this game is paced where it's not a
traditional shooter in the sense of
you're constantly just being thrown
enemies at you or like scripted
sequences it's more like they will kind
of mix in combat encounters with
puzzle-solving elements with platforming
ok than that assay but I think they do a
good job of having interesting combat
encounters where you'll come across an
enemy and they're they're kind of placed
in interesting ways or like oh I'm gonna
go this way to grab this ammo and then
oh there's a turret that kind of like is
off to the side to surprise you in
moments like that I think are kind of
like where the game still shines and was
still I was still enjoying myself when I
was playing it I was kind of surprised
how much I was enjoying myself
yeah me too when I was playing it I
don't know if I would play the whole
game again cuz I came in
long and kind of I felt like I got kind
of I think the ending kind of week oh I
definitely want to talk okay we'll get
to that but one more thing about the
combat is that the enemies have very
specific movesets so it's um they're not
unpredictable so once you understand how
they work it you understand like the
tactics that you need to use so it's all
these variables that get thrown into
these combat sequences yeah I think
that's that's a clever way for 1998 in
1998 to make a first-person shooter a
lot more interesting than what was
available back then no it's not there's
not just combat in half-life obviously
there's also puzzle solving there is
platforming elements which is strange
for a first-person shooter I would say
looking back at this but in the in the
case of half-life this is how they mix
up you know firefights you know you're
not going to be constantly shooting
things you need some sort of way to take
a breath from from the actual combat so
you want to want to say your piece about
platforming and puzzles in half I like
the idea of the platforming in puzzles
it doesn't it doesn't feel good anymore
and I think a lot of it has to do with
the way the movement feels it's really
slippery you move you move like just a
little too quick you have to hold down
like the shift key to like really slow
that you can like because you just fall
off like all the time like this is the
kind of game where you like you are
constantly hitting f5 to save because
you are gonna fall to your death
so often it's not just that there's all
this platforming is that you'll get
really really long stretches of
platforming where you're just doing that
and there's no combat and I think I
think they could have done a better job
kind of mixing the two like more often I
feel like yeah there's a little bit of a
pacing issue that I noticed going back
to it where I was I was pretty burnt out
on specific like platforming or puzzle
sequences and going back to the the
slippery feel of the movement like
that's classic half-life Gold Source
engine stuff and it's still a lot of
those sequences I'm just like tapping W
yeah I need to get to the edge of this
thing so I don't fall off right
later on and like at the very at tail
end of the game he started doing this
weird sequence but like teleporters and
trying to combine like figuring out
where these teleporters take you lining
them up with moving platforms and like
okay I get it this is this isn't very
fun anymore
for the for the time it was like this is
how this is what we can come up with to
break things up sure and I like it in
the early sequences and kind of like the
way they design the levels where they're
really trying to like make you feel like
you're in this facility you know there's
like these large massive areas and then
these kind of small like office
complexes and they're really big levels
especially for back then and I feel like
even today bilah even like most standard
like shooter campaigns these are still
pretty large levels you're dealing with
but they're almost a little too large
like there's a section early on where
you're going through these vents and I
just got lost because there's five
different vents you can go through and
they go in all sorts of directions some
of them lead interesting secrets other
just lead to nowhere and I think they
were just trying to kind of make it as
big as possible but at a certain point I
just kind of got frustrated with it yeah
and that's a another thing too is that
when you think about shooters or just
single-player games in general today is
that there's there's hints there's clear
indications of where you need to go
sometimes there's waypoints now I'm not
asking for all games that have waypoints
I can generally figure out where to go
in games but there's something about the
way half-life looks and where you can
get stuck pretty easily like where do I
go next where's a button I'm supposed to
press did I activate the scripted
sequence yeah leads to the next section
I don't know like there has to do with
the fact that like certain doors or
buttons aren't different looking for the
ones that you can't open so you just
kind of try every door and you try every
button when you get stuck and alright
eventually like I feel like when I was
playing yesterday I was having I got
through pretty quick and I feel like it
was just because of my knowledge of the
game but I've kind of retained and I
remember when I first played it there
were definitely points where I was just
getting frustrated and I would like kind
of look up a guy to play all right where
the hell am I supposed to go
hey mr. Bremen I had a bunch of messages
for you but we had a system crash about
20 minutes ago and I'm still trying to
find my files just one of those days I
guess I want to jump over to the
narrative style because half-life really
set itself apart by doing what you would
call it like the single shot you don't
narrative the it never the camera never
leaves Gordon's eyes right so from from
the minute you start to the very end
everything is told through Gordon
Freeman and it never jumps either yeah
never skips time at all it's all like
one continuous yeah like you said one
continuous shot in a way sort of so you
essentially experience this whole thing
as him there's never any anything to
kind of tell you what's happening behind
the scenes you know just as much as
Gordon does in terms of what's happening
why are these Marines descending on
Black Mesa why are these alien forces
invading our universe whatever so you
are kind of uncovering the mystery along
with him and it's uh it's effective I
think it's still you know effective
today in the sense that as I'm playing
through this I can see someone who's
genuinely like they want to see this
mystery play out like what is actor yeah
I think it's still it still totally
holds up it it was way more
revolutionary back when it first you
know when the game first came out like
that style of storytelling you think of
like the trans scene and the way the
game like doesn't start with just
shooting yeah there's that whole
extended scene around the tram and then
you're going through the facility and
then and there's a really good payoff
because then you go back through the
facility after the residents cast gates
happened and you see like you know all
the damage and destruction and everyone
dead and that's like really cool
storytelling that was kind of the first
game to really do that in a shooter and
that aspect isn't particularly unique
anymore every game has kind of done that
sense then I mean like Dhoom 3 like you
know stole kind of from half-life and a
lot of course yeah but I do think that
the like specific style of storytelling
of like this kind of singular focus on
just a protagonist
still works I think half-life is one of
the few series that like really nails
the silent protagonist yeah as a concept
I there's something about the way
half-life feels and its narrative and
that still feels unique to half-life and
it's sequels that I do feel like no game
is ever truly captured yeah and that's
something that like even though I think
half-life it still is really dated it
still kind of feels unique environmental
storytelling that term gets thrown
around a lot nowadays but there's
something about half-life and where
there's just like hints left all around
the Black Mesa facility to kind of tell
you what happened like g-man showing up
in the background yeah and like the
little little sprinkling of g-man every
now and then you're kind of like chasing
this dude but you kind of don't know
what his deal is
and just the mess that gets left behind
after this tragic event at this
laboratory it's I mean it's kind of par
for the course nowadays and narrative
styles but to see that play out when I
was a kid that was like genuinely
fascinated credibly make yeah credibly
unique at the time genuinely fascinated
by the story of Black Mesa what these
scientists were doing
[Music]
one thing you touched on earlier it was
how you know in 1998 this is this is how
storytelling was done in videogames like
the voice acting isn't great the
animations aren't great of course they
don't these characters don't look
particularly Billy and ugly but when we
revisited it today is that it's almost
plays out like a dark comedy in many
ways
yeah it's like watching a b-movie it's
like I think some of it was intentional
I think other parts of it weren't but it
yet added this like goofy charm mm-hmm
to it where you know there'd be this one
scientist is like oh hello goat and I
like I let me help you get through this
area and like while he's talking to me
there's just a dude behind him who's
like being like strangled and like
choked to death by this alien or you'd
have this guy be like ah let's become
and lock that door for you and then he
like immediately gets shot or something
and the AI is so bad that it just kind
of added to like the ridiculousness of
yeah like that just felt so silly and I
I was having a lot of fun with that yeah
yeah and you were mentioning that you
can ask security guards to watch your
back give you cover and then you would
be engaging with the enemy aliens and
then this fool is trying to try to shoot
aliens too but he's like hitting you in
the baby was shooting me in the back
got one going back to now and has that
charm because of how ridiculous it is
and like asking scientists a follow me
and they're like oh I can't follow you
anymore I'm not going any further
there's a lot of there's a lot of funny
things in half-life that much is a bit
so I mentioned earlier that I think the
game quality sort of falls near the end
and you said you actually played a bit
of the ending yeah recently I played
about the last third of the entire game
some yeses and nonsense all the Zen this
game goes from zero to 100 real quick
it's it's kind of bizarre in the sense
that you know I was talking about and
covering the mystery of what black Mesa
was doing and then you get to a point
where there's teleporters and then you
reach a point where it's all right
you're gonna we're gonna set this portal
up and then you're gonna go into this
other world that's in space and to fight
the mother alien or whatever the hell's
going on it turns into this like space
low gravity platformer did you enjoy it
because I remember even back when the
game came out people didn't like that
yeah I I don't I wasn't particularly
fond of it because like there's no real
boss battles in half-life and that's
cool but there's just this spider with a
big sack that you just keep shooting and
then it runs through different areas of
this alien world and you keep chasing it
and keep shooting it and it not that it
has to make sense but it just felt
pretty out of place and compared to the
rest of the game compared to the rest of
the game and then when I played it just
a couple days ago I was there - like oh
yeah this is like really weird I don't
necessarily think that that sequence is
like that ending part is great but that
last bit where g-man is talking to you
and kind of tying it all back together
was I remember what that felt like to
make it to the end of the game and you
know not necessarily find out what he's
all about but you know to have this guy
talking to you and still have a lot of
mystery left even at after the
conclusion of the game so there are bits
and pieces where I think that the ending
of half-life is pays off but also it has
me scratching my head even to this day
yeah cuz we'll never know there will be
a half-life 3 men oh I have recommended
your services to my employers and they
have authorized me to offer you a job
they agree with me that you have
limitless potential but should you play
half-life 1 that's the question yes so
now that was what our opening question
is that's the whole point of the show
nostalgia trip but I think that for me I
would answer that by saying what do you
want like do you want to have play
something that's really fun that's
that's very exciting in terms of combat
and you know storytelling and I would
say that you should play half-life if
your objective is to understand the
history of games where first-person
shooters came from and kind of be a
historian and document right how much
things have changed since 1998
but if I'm gonna if you ask me like oh
if there's a what shooter should I play
I'm probably not gonna recommend
half-life now I would almost recommend
Black Mesa if that's your objective it's
okay fun shooter which is a for those
who don't know it's a a fan recreation
of half-life that they've been working
on for like 10 10 plus years at this
point you can get it on Steam they're
still working on it
they're almost got Zen in there oh geez
best part if anything I was like oh no
no you're done you don't need to treat
the demon I'm curious to see if they
actually like change it and stuff how it
gets pulled off exactly because I do
think the game actually does a good job
of recreating half the good parts of
half-life but also not feeling afraid to
change things and improve on things when
they need to the shooting feels a lot
better
he uses the half-life 2 engine so they
incorporate like a lot of physics
puzzles and stuff like that it's if
you're just looking for like a good like
oh what's up what's the best version of
half-life and like a modern sense it'd
probably be that version yeah but yeah
if you're looking from like an archival
sort of like yeah I'm like a videogame
archaeologist who wants to uncover this
game then yeah check out the original or
turn up the source I played Isis I
played the original version in a way I
play it half-life source you played
source there they're mostly the same
except for a couple changes to better
textures I made on white stuff water
looks better some of the physics is a
little different in tours like native
widescreen so they play it plays
extremely well on modern machines I mean
we always recognize half-life as one of
the greatest games of all time whether
or not it holds up today is kind of I
would say no but it's still important to
recognize its place in history because
if you think about between 1998 where
half-life 1 came out and half-life 2
came out in 2004 games rapidly evolved
between that's a 6-year gap in which a
lot of games took notes from half-life
and you said this earlier as well is
that when you revolutionize the genre
and everyone wants to pull elements from
you right you end up looking like the
most dated game and I think that's what
happened to half-life absolutely when I
replayed it leading up to at the release
of half-life 2 I was like oh man this is
uh this might not be as great as I
remember it
but that's because there are so many
games that pulled from half-life to kind
of create their own great games so in
that sense I think that half-life is
still valuable to play to see where
games came from right there you go you
don't have to play it but you gotta
respect it yes put some respect on
half-life
that's our episode of a solid ship let
us know in the comments what you think
how you feel about half-life today and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
welcome to grave hoppers the show where
we put permadeath into every game you
die in a game you move on to the next oh
my god dude you had no he'll join us
live every Thursday 2:00 p.m. Pacific
don't miss it
what hit me
[Music]